[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la gran cita política que se nos avecina
señalada en rojo en el calendario el
próximo 3 de noviembre elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu ese duelo entre
donald trump y joe biden para ello me
acompañan en este estudio dos invitados
tres invitados que conocen perfectamente
la realidad en eeuu de yo fueron de
hecho fueron corresponsales allí y marc
based corresponsal del país en francia
bienvenido marc hola muchas gracias
eusebio vall corresponsal de la
vanguardia bienvenido eusebio muchas
gracias y desde eeuu desde nueva york
nos acompaña nuestra corresponsal
silvina szperling sí divina buenas
madrugadas allí
buen día a todos como hoy analizamos los
factores que pueden marcar el duelo
entre trump y viven en primera plana
quedan seis semanas tan solo ya para esa
fecha tan señalada el 3 de noviembre de
las elecciones en eeuu por el momento
según los últimos sondeos la distancia
prima
por el momento el ticket demócrata entre
llueva de mi cámara harry sacaría entre
5 o 6 puntos aproximadamente a la dupla
republicana formada por donald trump y
mike pence p atención porque sobran las
razones para apuntalar que el resultado
puede ser muy incierto entre ellas el
contexto de coronavirus y como cambia
además como consecuencia varias reglas
del sistema electoral de ello vamos a
hablar hoy también vamos a hablar de los
temas que pueden marcar esta campaña
prima el coronavirus pero por supuesto
también hablaremos del momento black
lights matter también de los incendios
que están asolando la costa oeste de los
constantes pulsos de donald trump con la
ciencia o del acuerdo histórico que se
ha firmado esta misma semana en la casa
blanca entre enemigos hasta ahora
irreconciliables como lo eran
emiratos árabes unidos bahrein e israel'
de todo ello vamos a hablar ahora pero
antes algunas portadas que ilustran esta
cita electoral del cougar internacional
aquí en francia califica en su portada
estas elecciones como las de
los peligros vamos a hablar hoy de ello
san francisco chronicle negación
climática mientras california ar de la
revista 'time' con una portada
cuantificando los destrozos de la
pandemia en eeuu o el new york post que
dedica una portada a la elección de
kamala harris como ticket de joe biden a
la vicepresidencia bajo el titular
haciendo juego de palabras camaradas
bueno marc si algo le faltaba este
particular 2020 es un elemento más de
volatilidad política como suponen las
elecciones en eeuu sin embargo la
historia muestra que en los países
desarrollados en principalmente en eeuu
no hay un riesgo sistémico gane quien
gane pero le pregunto estas elecciones y
que sus tienen más factores de riesgo
sistémico en esta ocasión posiblemente
primero por el contexto de pandemia
y el contexto de crisis económica brutal
y después por las características del
ocupante de la casa blanca el amigo del
presidente
donald trump que ya ha sugerido en
varias ocasiones que podría no estar
conforme o cuestionar el resultado
electoral sí sí le resulta adverso hay
pocos precedentes de que un resultado
sea impugnado por un presidente y que no
acepte
abandonar la casa blanca pero yo creo
que nos estamos adelantando varias
pantallas todavía deben celebrar esas
elecciones debe conocerse el resultado y
ella ya se verá lo que lo que va a
ocurrir
eeuu es una es una democracia con un
sistema constitucional de equilibrio de
poderes y de contrapoderes yo creo que
muy sólido y creo que una de las cosas
positivas que puede extraerse de los
cuatro años de presidencia de trump es
que este sistema funciona y que el
presidente no puede hacerlo y no me
tiene todos los poderes y por lo tanto
yo creo que hay que confiar en que ese
sistema funcione también en las próximas
elecciones de noviembre se vio como
calibramos el impacto de el coronavirus
en todas dentro de esta elección bueno
es evidente que en eeuu como en la
mayoría de países los gobiernos han
tenido grandes dificultades para
afrontar esta crisis siempre intentando
ese balance entre salud y economía que
no es
también en eeuu se han cometido muchos
errores
se ha hablado de este enfrentamiento con
los científicos pero yo no creo que eso
vaya a ser determinante en esta elección
porque los dos bandos están muy
consolidados hay una selección hay una
división muy clara
es una factura que se ha ido que se ha
ido profundizando en ese país y es un
factor más yo creo que más en el sentido
de los resultados y de la incertidumbre
que puede haber por el voto por correo
que podemos entrar en una fase peligrosa
de incertidumbre y de reacciones
imprevistas no sólo de parte de los
políticos sino de la gente que está más
crispada que mucho más que crispa que
hace diez o quince años
silvina faltan seis semanas para la
celebración de las elecciones de
atención porque hay muchas voces que
anuncian que a lo mejor al vencedor
falta más tiempo para conocerles sin
duda es un año marcado por la pandemia
que cambia las reglas del sistema
electoral en qué consiste en estos
cambios silvina por hacer un rápido
resumen
bueno lo decir muy bien o sea ya no se
dice aquí que vamos a tener un elector
nairo es una noche electoral y nos habla
de una semana electoral y quizás hasta
de meses
o sea el problema cuál es que la
pandemia realmente ha cambiado los
verbos del juego electoral
principalmente porque es una elección
histórica por la cantidad de gente que
va a votar por correo
más de 100 millones de personas quizás
van a emitir su voto por esta vía y
además en este contexto en el que trump
habla de un posible fraude si es que el
voto se emite por correo cosa que ya ha
sido desbancada porque no hay indicios
ni evidencias en el pasado de que haya
habido fraude marc que la economía era
sin duda la gran base electoral que
tenía donald trump hasta que llegó la
pandemia es a esa gran baja la que se va
a ceñir en la que tenía claro que iba a
pasar toda esta campaña electoral pero
esto ha sido totalmente trastocado
nuestra gran baza que tenía si la
economía y la recesión económica que es
consecuencia de la pandemia o por lo
menos de las medidas que se han tomado
en eeuu como en otros países de la
pandemia es decir el confinamiento que
para la economía mundial durante unos
dos meses esto cambia totalmente el
panorama yo diría que trump tenía
las acciones más favorables para trump
antes de coronavirus que después
trump se había beneficiado de una
economía en crecimiento y un paro que
había bajado a niveles históricos que
venía de antes de barack obama todas las
medidas que se adoptaron durante la
presidencia de barack obama después de
la de la crisis financiera y económica
del 2008 pero este crecimiento y esta
reducción del desempleo continuó y este
era su gran baza no era no era su mérito
no era todo su mérito que la economía
fuese también yo diría que tampoco hay
que decir ahora que sea toda su culpa
que la economía vaya tan mal sólo hay
que mirar los datos económicos en el
resto de países es decir yo entiendo que
el partido demócrata use este argumento
contra tram diciendo la economía de
trump está está hecha unos zorros pero
si somos y somos honestos no es no es
culpa de trump sólo hay que ver los
datos en españa en francia
en alemán y en cualquier país que ha
sufrido el impacto de coronavirus y qué
su economía y su población durante
durante meses
eusebio en hasta qué punto hay un cambio
de paradigma para eeuu pero sobre todo
para el mundo según gane uno u otro
vaivén otra porque yo creo que es un
debate esta pregunta se le suele
responder siempre de dos maneras bien
minimizando la importancia del que gane
o bien criticando que se minimice donde
donde se sitúa usted muy complicado
primero querría añadir a alguien que ha
dicho más respecto a la economía total
que valía ligado a tu pregunta es decir
más allá de la coyuntura económica
yo creo que trump tiene algunas bazas a
su favor
por el hecho por ejemplo de su
enfrentamiento muy duro con china
el enfrentamiento muy duro con china y
eso le ayuda en el cierto electorado de
clase trabajadora en estados clave como
por ejemplo pensilvania ohio
es decir cuidado con con ver que la
situación económica le perjudica tanto
quizás quizás la gente de más allá en el
horizonte y cree que él va a hacer unas
políticas que van a ayudar a los
sectores deprimidos a la industria
americana es decir y ahora vuelvo a la
pregunta no es decir yo creo que a veces
se exagera un poco el que trump suponga
un cambio de paradigma es decir en el
pulso con china existía antes ciertas
políticas internacionales de de estados
y no se llaman dicen game and no debe
dejarse de implicar en el mundo dejarse
de implicar en oriente medio y ahora se
habían iniciado obama también es decir
es evidente que trump le ha dado una
retórica mucho más agresiva a veces
incomprensible exagerada visto desde
ojos europeos pero hay una serie de
fundamentales que quizás no cambian
tanto y que hay una línea de continuidad
más más visible más más evidente de lo
que a simple vista podría parecer hemos
pedido a nuestra corresponsal en nueva
york a silvina este bien que nos haga
una radiografía de cómo están las cosas
ya seis semanas de las elecciones de los
últimos sondeos entre que públicos sean
fianza cada uno de los candidatos y los
estados que pueden ser claves cuéntanos
silvina
bueno yo tengo un poco de deja vú con
las elecciones del 2016 todo en sentido
que los mismos estados clave vuelven
estar hoy en el centro de la escena
michigan wisconsin y pensilvania y
nuevamente florida florida le preocupa
por demás a bailén porque porque no está
teniendo muy buena excepción con los
latinos tiene menos llegada a los
latinos que la que tenía hillary clinton
en el 2016 y ya sabemos que hillary
perdió contra trump el estado de florida
así que haciendo lo imposible lo vimos
hasta bailando la canción del 11 y
despacito que después éste fue izada por
la campaña de donald trump para ponerle
imágenes débil como abrazando por atrás
que es una de las grandes manchas nos
falta más bien a hayden especialmente
está muy preocupado
por tener el vodka creo que es crucial
no solamente en florida sino en arizona
en carolina corte o sea es la primera
minoría que tiene mucho peso en estas
flexiones aquí la fórmula baile kamala
harris o coman la harris como le gusta
que pronunció su nombre tiene mucho
atractivo porque porque muchas de las
mujeres ya es como que un poco colgaron
los botines aunque pueda haber una
candidata presidenta lo intentaron
muchísimo y este es el momento no está
mal las carnes tiene 55 años es la más
joven de los dos de las dos fórmulas
realmente tiene energía y hay muchas
voces que dicen que probablemente pueda
llegar a terminar un mandato si hayden
tiene algún problema va a ir en va a
llegar en caso de ganar con 78 años a la
presidencia me gustaría hablar de los
temas que van a marcar como lo comentaba
antes esta campaña y todo un abanico el
coronavirus prima pero tenemos pues del
blog el del momento en black del black
friday light máter tenemos los incendios
en california la actitud de trump
cuál crees que va a predominar en esta
campaña que te más difícil no lo sé yo
brothers muchos temas y a la vez la
política ya desde hace tiempo no son
temas ni son programas son emociones el
contexto son los temas que has
mencionado el coronavirus a la economía
son el contexto pero que hay una batalla
e identitaria entre las estas dos
américas muy fuerte que determinará
enseguida la palabra o se ve antes
hacemos una breve pausa y enseguida
continuamos en primera plana
[Música]
ah
durante la pandemia del cómic 19 perú
con 15% de estudiantes universitarios
abandonaron sus carreras y en el segundo
semestre la estadística alcanzaría el 35
por ciento la federación de
instituciones privadas de educación
superior alerta que más de 350 mil
estudiantes universitarios dejarían de
estudiar por falta de recursos
económicos para remediar esta coyuntura
el gobierno peruano de 138 millones de
dólares para impulsar 10.000 becas y 3
mil créditos paralelamente algunos
bancos también promueven programas de
becas pero algunos congresistas
sostienen que las ayudas no son
suficientes y plantean un proyecto de
ley para eliminar el cobro de cuotas de
ingreso a las universidades existe un
grupo importante de estudiantes que
trabajan para solventar sus estudios
pero el 30% de jóvenes peruanos
perdieron sus empleos durante la
pandemia según un estudio de la
fundación forge la eventualidad ha
propiciado que la cantidad de chicas y
chicos que no estudian ni trabajan- se
amplíen por eso diversos colectivos
reclaman una educación justa y
equitativa señalan que un mejor nivel
educativo reduce sustancialmente las
probabilidades de
caer en situaciones de pobreza
[Música]
irán ha comenzado este nuevo año
académico en un momento en el que el
gobierno ha aceptado que está llegando a
la tercera hora del cobi 19 la
inauguración del año universitario ha
hecho por el presidente a sandro hand y
habló de que parte de la carrera del
azul que las clases se iban dar por
internet pero muchas también se darían
presenciales y esto pone en un mayor
dilema a las universidades que ya se
vieron en problemas en marzo pasado
cuando cerraron las aulas primero porque
no estaban preparadas para dar clases
por internet segundo porque muchísimos
estudiantes no tenían acceso al internet
especialmente en áreas más alejadas del
país y tercero porque los profesores no
tenían el conocimiento esto llevó a que
muchos estudiantes decidieran cancelar o
congelar el último semestre del año
pasado y después de muchos días dudas el
ministerio de ciencias decidió aceptarlo
por motivos especiales pero se conoce
que este año vuelve a suceder lo mismo
muchos estudiantes quieren congelar la
carrera primero porque no quieren las
condiciones de internet y segundo porque
no se ven en capacidad de regresar a las
aulas en un momento en el que el cob y
19 sigue afectando al país
[Música]
a lo largo del mes de septiembre tiene
lugar en españa la segunda convocatoria
de las pruebas de acceso a la
universidad y por lo tanto también la
segunda tanda de inscripciones
universitarias por lo que no disponemos
todavía de una imagen fija sobre si han
podido disminuir las matriculaciones
debido a la crisis económica ligada al
coronavirus pero por otro lado la lucha
para que a disminuyan las tasas
universitarias tiene años de recorrido
en el movimiento estudiantil y es algo
que está previsto por el actual
ejecutivo pero por lo que todavía hay un
par de años de margen de ejecución pero
por otro lado también el gobierno
decretó esta primavera un aumento de más
del 20 por ciento del presupuesto para
las becas de educación y universidades
pero hay que tener en cuenta que estas
ayudas se calculan en base a las rentas
familiares de los últimos dos años por
lo tanto las familias que hayan visto
decrecer su capital económico
exclusivamente en función de la
situación actual no van a ser
beneficiarias de estas ayudas
[Música]
me muerdo los labios para no llamarte
con tus besos
donde ellos sentimientos directores en
cantantes bailarines y otros personajes
de la cultura nos hablan sin rodeos
sobre sus carreras y vivencias
personales lo que nos acerca aún más a
su público somos una banda que también
somos aburguesado
seguimos en primera plana hoy hablando
de las elecciones presidenciales que
eeuu celebrará el próximo 3 de noviembre
lo hacemos con marc bassets corresponsal
del país en francia eusebio valdez
corresponsal corresponsal de la
vanguardia y nuestra corresponsal en
nueva york
silvina este link hablábamos con marca
antes de la pausa eusebio de los temas
de ese abanico de temas amplio que
pueden marcar esta campaña como los
calibramos de toda la variedad de temas
cuales sabría que efectivamente algunos
que parecen descontados no para ambos
bandos como comen como comentaba antes
sucedió que parece que ya están si
hablamos de cambio climático o de
medidas preventivas de coronavirus la
factura es la fractura es tan tremenda
en la sociedad que parece que hay
sistemas que están un poco descontados
no sí pero como decía marx que este tema
identitario la fractura
este sentimiento de comunidad que tienen
los dos bandos es fundamental por
ejemplo el tema climático de los
incendios es posible que influya mucho
en el votante de california pero en
california está claro que van a ganar
los demócratas y es la cuestión
económica
[Música]
bueno a los primeros los primeros años
de trump
la economía iba muy bien es decir
yo creo que también hay que tener en
cuenta que estas elecciones no sólo se
se elige un presidente se elige
la totalidad de la cámara de
representantes un tercio del senado y es
estado por estado con una problemática
muy concreta y está en juego quién va a
dominar el congreso también porque el
tram por ejemplo confía en poder incluso
es difícil arrebatar la mayoría la
cámara de representantes de dirá hay
muchos muchos elementos en juego no sólo
temáticos sino en cada estado por
públicos elementos que pueden definir
esta contienda
silvina muchos analistas consideran que
esta vez es clave el voto de las mujeres
cuán tan decisivo es este elemento visto
lo que pasó con hillary clinton y las
mujeres blancas hace cuatro años si en
realidad yo no tengo un desayuno con la
campaña del 2016 vuelven y vuelven a
hacer clave los mismos estados
pensilvania wisconsin michigan y florida
el estado de florida por ejemplo le
preocupa mucho a joe biden había
comenzado teniendo una leve ventaja que
cada
está cerrando y qué pasa si el voto
latino y de la r sobre todo es
fundamental y no lo está pudiendo lograr
incluso tiene menos llegada de menos
menos recepción con los latinos de los
20 días claro y clinton y hillary
clinton perdió en el 2006 el estado de
florida sí que está muy complicado y
tiene poco tiempo porque en florida por
ejemplo como en muchos otros estados se
puede votar antes del 3 de noviembre
entonces tiene poco tiempo para cortejar
al electorado es crucial mar recorrió en
su libro del otoño americano además
hablamos de ese libro en este programa
hace hace unos meses la realidad de los
votantes de trump claro ahora mar que
está aquí no puede estar sondeando lo
que sí
si pudiéramos saber cómo ha evolucionado
ese voto o qué grado de satisfacción han
tenido esos votantes o qué razones
darían ahora para volver a votar a trump
como lo podríamos valorar con la
distancia siempre aquellos entre la
gente que entrevista esté en aquel libro
si cuesta mucho
evaluarlo desde la distancia pero si
miramos los sondeos yo creo que una cosa
que llama mucho la atención es la
fidelidad del votante republicano
nos hemos fijado mucho y en el libro yo
me fijaba mucho en este votante blanco
de clase trabajadora que anteriormente
había sido demócrata ligado a los
sindicatos y que con la
desindustrialización de el cinturón
industrial de eeuu de estos estados que
mencionaba él se vio en pensilvania ohio
michigan pues habían pedido el trabajo y
habían pasado a votar a trump que era el
candidato que les defendía lo que se
presentaba como vamos a cerrar las
fronteras al comercio vamos a
enfrentarnos a méxico a china a acabar
con las deslocalizaciones esta es una
parte del votante de trump y es la parte
que decantó su victoria porque estos
fueron los estados en el que un puñado
de votos que fueron 50.000 y 80.000
acabaron dándole la victoria a trump
pero tran gana también por muchos más
votantes del partido republicano citó de
memoria pero creo que la cifra de apoyo
de tram en el partido republicano es más
del 90 por ciento de republicanos que
que son atrás son tres pistas y estamos
van de un candidato que mirado fríamente
objetivamente es antagónico como lo que
ha representado el partido republicano
durante décadas en la política exterior
en los valores morales etcétera celano
sin embargo ahí está fidelidad de mismo
que me daba mucha atención de lo que ha
pasado en estos años que es que el
votante republicano y no sólo la clase
trabajadora blanca que tenemos nuestro
foco pero el bando republicano clásico
no de clase trabajadora forzosamente de
clase media media-alta
este establishment el votante también
religioso no delante de las regiones y
el segmento evangélico fundamentalista
cristiano ha sido muy fiel a un
candidato que se podría decir que se ha
reído a la cara de toda esta gente no
para mí el gran enigma y el gran
fenómeno de eeuu de estos años y por lo
que parece no hay una desencanto no ni
una huida de este tipo de votante hacia
hacia el partido demócrata y sin embargo
esta semana hemos visto se vio un
acuerdo histórico en la casa blanca
entre enemigos históricos
irreconciliables
israel emiratos árabes unidos y bahrein
sellado esta semana en la casa blanca
decía el diario le monde esta semana que
ha venido a salvar un poco los muebles
en el balance diplomático de donald
trump claro el problema es que pretende
donald trump con este movimiento de cara
a las elecciones porque a priori sus
votantes no estarían tan en el meollo de
este tipo de estrategias internacionales
aquí públicos se dirigirá a un perfil
más clásico del republicanismo que
todavía sigue desconfiando de donald
trump para mostrar que sí que puede
hacer cosas yo creo que precisamente
estos acuerdos con bahrein y los
emiratos
juegan en un estado decisivo como
florida que ahora lo comentaba vuestra
corresponsable en florida ganó trump por
la mínima en el 2016
y ahora pues hay un elemento en el voto
judío en florida viven muchos judíos
muchos judíos de mayores que vivían en
nueva york que han ido a pasar su red su
retiro en florida es un segmento pequeño
pero que puede entonces es este tipo de
acuerdo es evidente que favorece el voto
judío para trump pues ahí ahí ahí puede
estar una de las claves en el estado de
florida
estos acuerdos se han conseguido por un
presidente que se ha enfrentado al
establishment eso es lo más sorprendente
de todos no sea trump está haciendo
políticas contra el establishment del
departamento de estado del pentágono o
incluso de la cia y le está saliendo
aparentemente bien no se ha decidió
trasladar la capital la capital de o sea
trasladar la embajada de eeuu de tel
aviv a jerusalén parecía un anatema pues
no ha pasado nada ahora consigue estos
acuerdos es evidente que esto tiene un
rédito electoral' y en estados que
pueden ser clave como florida y quería
añadir una cosa en el análisis es decir
parece que esté diciendo esté previendo
la autoría de tram no simplemente
trump según las encuestas está ganando
terreno entre el votante hispano y entre
el votante afroamericano y entre el
votante judío tres minorías no va a
ganar estas minorías va a quedarse muy
lejos pero sí hará araña votos en estas
minorías y eso le puede ayudar michigan
le puede ayudar en pensilvania le puede
ayudar en florida y puede decantar la
elección vamos a comentar algunos temas
todavía que nos faltan en el tintero por
ejemplo la elección
marc de kamala harris como ticket de joe
biden que aporta kamala harris a joe
biden como tick 1 históricamente el
vicepresidente influye muy poco casi
nunca es decisivo ni ni cambia los
sondeos ni ni ni tiene un impacto en el
resultado esta vez se verá igual hay
quizás es posible que haya factores
nuevos no una es la edad de joe biden
job aiden se presenta implícitamente
como un presidente de un para un solo
mandato
nadie piensa que pueda una y piensa
luego la política da unos giros
sorprendentes pero a priori es un hombre
mayor no se piensa que pueda estar ocho
años en caso de que ganase por lo tanto
es un ticket en el que el mensaje yo
creo que el mensaje subtexto es kamala
harris puede ser la sucesora de yo bailé
otra cosa que me llama la atención en el
nombramiento la nominación de kamala
harris es que es una candidata centrista
no la vilipendiada a la centrista del
partido demócrata representado por los
clinton pero también por obama y que los
últimos años con el auge después de
bernie sanders de alexandra ocasión de
esta congresista de nueva york a la
izquierda había
sido mucho peso y había ese un poco la
voz del partido demócrata ante ante tram
pues se ha esfumado aquí el partido de
demócratas sigue siendo un hombre de la
vieja guardia que lleva la desde
principio de los 70 en política como yo
bailé y una
y una candidata que también representa
esta línea la de obama al de los clinton
y de baile ahora veremos veremos el
impacto y yo yo cree yo dudo y
basándonos también en la historia que
sea decisiva a la elección del
vicepresidente observen la pregunta que
planea sobre esta cita electoral y no me
resulta hacérsela creen en la
posibilidad de que done el tren no
reconozca los resultados que se produzca
en el próximo 3 de noviembre es decir
esa posibilidad de que incluso la
constitución es inconstitucional pero
que se aferre al poder de alguna forma
es un riesgo si la noche electoral la
cosa no está clara si falta por
contabilizar los votos por correo todo
apunta que eso puede pasar que es una
posibilidad muy real y eso puede pasar
puede pasar que la noche electoral en el
voto real de ese día por ejemplo ganará
trump y después con el recuento
es imponente se impusiera by declaró a
menudo lío entonces bueno yo creo que el
peligro está en que no no no es el año
2000 ya no es el duelo bus
korn en el que ambos fueron muy
civilizados tanto ellos dos como sus
votantes hubo mucha discusión hubo
pleitos con los abogados pero se mantuvo
la calma en cambio ahora esto no está
garantizado el país ha cambiado y hay
mucha más crispación este es el peligro
pues muchísimas gracias por haberme
acompañado y en este análisis de la cita
electoral del 3 de noviembre en eeuu un
placer y a todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí en primera plana la próxima semana
muchas gracias